if I were to describe the basic
mechanics of middle-earth shadow of
Mordor to you you'd think I was actually
talking about Assassin's Creed on the
surface shadow of Mordor is assassin's
creed set on the Lord of the Rings
universe you ascends tall structures and
engage in rhythmic combat against large
numbers of swordsmen you activate a
special mode of vision that allows you
to identify objects and people of
interest
I wouldn't call shadow of Mordor a
ripoff but its inspirations are clear
that doesn't mean that shadow of Mordor
isn't great on its own terms though you
hold a single button to rush up towers
and leap improbable distances and fluid
animations make the locomotion feel
breezy and fun an uber karcher may be
waiting atop that Tower but no matter
another button allows you to stab them
from below or you could always sneak up
from behind and sync your hidden blade I
need your totally unhidden dagger into
his sticky flesh
shadow of Mordor shares some of the
camera and move inflatables that can
make assassin's creed irritating but it
also greatly refines and improves other
aspects of that formula combat for
instance has a similar kind of flow but
it's more challenging than you might be
used to hordes of Eric ice around you
and your experience with other games
might fool you into thinking you can
manage the mob but there are times when
we must simply run to face the irk swarm
even when your time your counter-attacks
properly is often to face your own
demise and subsequent resurrection I'm
looking for generating a captain shadow
of mordor features not just one hero but
- you are a ranger called tallien but
you are also a bitter Wraith who shares
Italiens body for all purposes tallien
should be dead but his spiritual
homecoming has been delayed by this
unholy union the two's journey of
discovery takes them through Mordor and
a nearby region where death and decay
are a common sight this Ranger Wraith
hybrid leads to shadow of Mordor
slickest moments when the wraiths anger
becomes all-consuming Italians face
melts away to reveal the apparition
underneath rage is a common emotion in
Mordor on the part of both the rape and
the uruk-hai Italian and his companion
face
unfortunately the story is too
disjointed to be called one of the best
Lord of the Rings tales Gollum is as
disquieting a presence as ever but for
every recognizable character there is a
less established one the game's main
villains appear before they're even
properly introduced
the incomplete storytelling combined
with a series of tepid final encounters
unfortunately softens the impact to
games conclusion the standard Eirik
higher your primary foes though captains
and WarChiefs are the most challenging
ones you'll face a captain's arrival is
a big deal
your sword meets the leaders the camera
zooms in and the Uruk taunts you upon a
first meeting the captain may promise
you a grisly dismemberment should you
die and face the same captain again
he'll wonder how you cheated death so to
say to go great maggot you'll be back
that dude ain't no such melodrama the
only problem with making a mountain out
of every molehill is one of pacing after
a while you can become annoyed by the
incessant theatrical introductions which
can really disrupt the flow
I finally caught again the cook mode i
captains aren't impossible to defeat of
course but you'll be better equipped to
beat them once you add a few additional
skills to your repertoire which you do
by performing missions and assassinating
enemies your greatest tool isn't your
blade though or your ghostly bow but the
uruk-hai themselves you can view the
Uruk eyes political hierarchy at a
glance but in order to learn a captain's
identity and combat weaknesses you need
Intel which you usually gain by taking
over in Eric's mind again overthrowing a
captain or war chief is not always a
walk in the park so knowing that your
enemy is invulnerable the stealth kills
makes all the difference
you can even instill fear in captain's
by shooting explosive barrels and
catching them on fire or by riding a
carriage or into battle oh did I not
mention you can mount a four-legged
Beast and command it to feast on auric
entrails well you can and it's awesome
shadow of Mordor second half introduces
even more ways to mess with Oryx Minds
ultimately you're able to command
individual captains in a system and
battle as they fight their way up the
pecking order the story gives this
system a purpose so that your political
shenanigans don't come across as
never-ending busy work so even without
narrative context the Nemesis system is
remarkably absorbing all of these tasks
are dotted across the game's too
expansive maps which invite you to chase
one Waypoint after another murdering
captains infiltrating auric feasts and
collecting artifacts that unveil truths
about the past what's great about shadow
of mordor isn't that it gives you so
much to do though but that it finds a
way to be unique even though it's
superficially so similar to another game
who would have thought that Mordor could
be such an inviting place to explore